okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p here
is an example of a trump estroux is so
so deep in conspiracy and bogus talking
points that i don't really know how to
reply to them but i do want to let you
know that these people exist and they're
allowed to vote which is why we need to
vote to counteract them take a listen
yeah i'm welcome to chill right now and
talk about President Trump and President
Obama president Trump is probably one of
the best person we've ever had and I
don't understand why I started he just
just wake up and see it when Obama was
president we had been infiltrated at the
highest level and you guys never caught
on to that but look at everything he did
it was not none of it was fro USA he
didn't a better our enemies Iran he
weaponized the FBI to spy on us hillary
was cylinder our uranium that's for
nuclear weapons they were he available
never fun they're our military they're
making a country ripe for picking thank
God didn't get in a swaddling portably
wolf President Roh a good day yeah I
have no response other than to say
that's what we're fighting against okay
you can't convince that person to vote
for someone other than Trump they may
live in a state where it doesn't really
matter because Trump's going to carry
the state our focus needs to be find
reasonable people and tell them it's
really important to vote because you are
not going to convince that Trump assess
who has devolved into all sorts of
ridiculous conspiracies to reconsider
his opinion okay it's get out the vote
not convinced rumpus to vote for a
democrat that's not the name of the game
great bonus show today we'll talk about
Boris Johnson becoming the British prime
minister we will talk about a 700
million dollar settlement
for Equifax after this massive breach I
actually my my identity identity has
been pseudo stolen I believe as a result
of that breach I'll talk about it on the
bonus show today get access to the bonus
show become a member or a patron I'll
speak to you then